begin with a developing story downtown
metro police is investigating a homicide
that happened off wyoming and las vegas
boulevard madison kimbrough joins us
live this evening with the details on
this madison
yeah as you can see behind me it's still
a very active scene you can see traffic
is busy but this shooting happened here
around 12 30 this afternoon
two men in their 30s were shot while
standing outside an apartment complex
near industrial road and chicago the
reasoning behind the shooting is unknown
but one of the men died the other is in
critical condition and is being treated
at umc it definitely appears like a
targeted incident
on at least one of the persons looks
like we had a couple males that were
standing outside when they were
ambushed and shot at currently there's
no suspect information and police say
it's unclear if the suspect took off
running or drove off but we do know
there were multiple shots fired
and keep it here on 8 news now as we
learn the latest details to this story
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now